[Musique]
on va commencer cette question sur est
demain en parlant de science fiction
ça paraît être une bonne manière de
rentrer en matière mais j'avais envie
quand j'ai discuté un petit peu avec les
personnes qui sont occupés de cette
journée de vous parler un petit peu
d'une autre manière de dire la
science-fiction effectivement
aujourd'hui en tout cas ça m'arrive
assez fréquemment qu'on nous dise
est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire de quoi
demain sera fait et que va être la
robotique de moins que vont être les
internautes artificielle demain et ma
réponse première c'est j'en sais rien
déjà parce que je suis pas prophète je
suis pas devant mais j'ai pas la
prétention de savoir vers quoi on va par
contre ce que je connais relativement
bien c'est ça que je vais vous présenter
aujourd'hui en 18 minutes c'est que pas
mal de gens des auteurs des
illustrateurs des réalisateurs ont
proposé par le biais de la fiction de
réfléchir non pas tant à ce demain qu'on
peut fantasmer qui s'est jamais vraiment
réaliser tel qu'on le souhaitait mais
plutôt à cette manière que le demain à
déjà d'être actif dans le quotidien et
c'est un peu cette espèce de grille de
lecture que j'ai envie de vous partager
aujourd'hui sur une thématique qui me
paraît assez intéressante qu'elle a
quittée matic dédia ou d intelligence
artificielle qu'on va remettre en lien
avec la thématique des robots
l'occurrence dans la science fiction il
ya une sorte de parcours qui se faire
entre les années 1920 et aujourd'hui et
qui passe par plusieurs thématiques
plusieurs figures qui vont du robot créé
en 1926 jusqu'aux ya aujourd'hui mais
comme toute conférence un peu intello on
va commencer par un schéma 1
habituellement la science fiction la
considère mais je vous promets que je
vous prends quelques quelques minutes
pour ça on la considère comme une
manière de lire notre futur ou de
décrire notre futur cette absurde vous
savez que lorsque vous prenez un roman
ben vous lisez pas du tout l'avis du
futur ou du présent ou du passé mais
vous voyez une mise en intrigue une
organisation fantasmes et fictionnel
d'événements dans lequel nous lecteurs
ou spectateur on va se plonger éprouver
des émotions
c'est ce qu'on appelle le récit dans le
récit de la fiction ce qui est assez
particulier dans la science fiction
c'est que ces récits et tous parmi vous
on avait vu
suppose dans votre vie bah ils ont
quelques liens bizarre c'est qu'il ya
des robots dans le monde réel
et puis à des robots dans la science
fiction il ya des cyborgs dans le monde
réel il ya des cyborgs la science
fiction etc jusqu'aux dia et nous on
fait comme on est pétri de ces scénarios
on passe notre temps à nous parler du
futur à revoir des films qui n'a pas vu
avatar qui n'a pas vu pour peut-être
vous n'êtes pas du tout les films dont
je parlais mais qui n'a pas vu
bladerunner etc
et puis tout ça on le garde parce que
l'avantagé de la fiction l'avantagent
des récits c'est qu'on se les
approprient et on y éprouve des émotions
le problème c'est que quand on pense au
futur de l'humanité au futur des robots
odesia on a d'appel n'a pas faire
interférer en fait les scénarios qu'on a
en tête et puis finalement la réalité
des chercheurs les chercheurs disent
nous ne faisons pas de la
science-fiction souhaite la vie les
auteurs de science-fiction disent nous
ne sommes pas des futurologues chouette
la vie mais le problème c'est que les
citoyens que nous sommes tous s'y sont
pas spécialistes de l'un ou de l'autre
ont tendance à juste titre de mélanger
or la différence c'est que dans la
science fiction et le titre de fiction
le stipule bien en fait le robot n'est
pas d'abord le robot de l'ingénieur
somme toute peu intéressants dans un
scénario de fiction mais il est d'abord
une métaphore et je vous rappelle que la
métaphore peut-être pour certains c'est
un vieux souvenir s'est pas d'abord une
jolie image pour écrire une lettre
d'amour bien que j'ai utilisé ce type
d'image quand j'avais 18 ans qui n'ont
pas marché mais c'est d'abord la seule
manière
la seule manière de décrire des réalités
anthropologiques
autrement dit comment vous expliquer
l'amour mieux qu'avec la flamme
amoureuse la flamme amoureuse est une
métaphore voit pas que c'est bien c'est
pas pour faire joli mais ça exprime
quelque chose qui est difficile à
exprimer autrement à la fois c'est
fascinant
ça attire à la fois ça peut être
répulsif à la fois sa consume on al
impression qu on entre à mourir à la
fois ça revigore toutes ces choses là
tous ces éléments là sont constitutifs
de cette métaphore tout bête la flamme
amoureuse et c'est pour ça qu'un
philosophe français qui s'appelle paul
ricoeur disait que la métaphore était la
seule manière que nous humains avons
pour re décrire le monde autrement et
pour eux décrit notre rapport au monde
on peut essayer de rld écrire autrement
mais la métaphore est une bonne manière
c'était un bon manière d'une bonne
manière dont là l'intelligence and human
ou la sensibilité humaine
capable de créer des nouvelles images
des nouvelles images pour comprendre
l'homme et le monde dans lequel il vit
et c'est cette lecture là que je vous
propose aujourd'hui à travers un
parcours assez rapide a évidemment vu le
temps qui m'est imparti entre les robots
et les ja les robots vous connaissez
peut-être cette pièce de théâtre si vous
la connaissez vous êtes malheureux parce
que c'est une mauvaise pièce de théâtre
il s'appelle et ruèrent écrit pour 1926
et une d'édition la première édition
anglaise de 1923 mais qui est écrite par
un écrivain tchèque karel capek qui
raconte dans cette pièce de théâtre en
scénario somme toute assez classique
aujourd'hui vous êtes sur une île une
usine on fabrique des êtres humains
dedans on leur a juste enlevé l'âme
c'est pratique c'est humain sans âme
sont des très bons ouvriers
sauf que un jour hélène jeune femme qui
est qui a pris en peu en pitié ces
robots se rend sur l'île séduit les
ingénieurs c'est pas très compliqué
séduit les ingénieurs et puis oblige un
des ingénieurs a insufflé de l'âme dans
ces robots 1 et leur insuffle de l'âme
est soudainement que font les rivaux ils
se révoltent et ils se révoltent ils
dessinent l'humanité la pièce de théâtre
se termine avec le fait que le dernier
humain dit au revoir aux robots qu'ils
vont recréer un monde
évidemment ce scénario qui a bientôt 100
ans aujourd'hui
on l'a encore dans les journaux quand on
nous parle du fait que les ja vont
détruire l'humanité où les robots vont
peut-être prendre le pas sur l'homme
mais c'est pas un truc très récents ou
par être à la pointe du progrès mais en
fait c'est pas le cas et ruèrent sur le
lit comme ça on va dire à mr capek avait
anticipé les questions qu'on se pose en
particulier depuis les années 60 70
pas du tout parce que capek comprendrait
quelque chose de très bien grâce à son
frère par ailleurs yosef c'est que le
mot robot en tchèque veut dire le
travailleur où l'esclave la traduction
la prostate est la plus juste serait le
prolétaire parce que vous connaissez
cette histoire de rer
lorsque vous construisez des hommes dans
une entreprise à qui vous ôtez la me
servir le siège de l'identité de
l'individualité pour qu'ils construisent
le monde
alors vous retrouvez la lutte des
classes marxiste autrement dit et rue r
et pas d'abord en récits qui parlent des
robots n'y a pas de robots des
ingénieurs dans les années 20 mais il
parle simplement d'une métaphore
l'histoire d'une métaphore d'une image
qui
parle de la condition des prolétaires
qui sont des humains de céret dos des
premiers robots sont des humains de
chair et d'os mais à qui on ôte
l'individualité
autrement dit les premiers robots sont
des humains qui sont aliénés par un
système capitaliste fabriqués par le
système industriel est incapable de
s'insurger sauf lorsqu'ils retrouvent
leur âme et je vous rappelle que ses
marques dans le communisme il ya cette
idée que les prolétaires doivent
conscientiser leurs conditions pour
ensuite être capable de se révolter est
de prendre le pas sur les capitalistes
c'est cette image du robot qui va être
encore un énorme succès aux états unis
la pièce est jouée 1921 à prague en 1922
à paris puis 1923 aux états unis en
particulier à new york qui va être
récupérée par les magazines populaires
américains qu'on appelle les pulp
magazines et dans ces pôles magazines on
va transformer ces robots de capek ici
on en 1926 on va transformer les robots
de capek on être de métal à l'aller les
religions américaine et les comités de
censure sur les magazines populaires
empêche l'homme de pouvoir recréer la
vie artificiellement l'homme peut créer
des machines artificiellement mais pas
des humains on va donc mécanisée les
roues et on connaît ces robots mécanisée
puisque nous on ne connaît tous ce
film-là qui arrive en 1927 fritz lang
basé sur un roman de sa femme thea von
harbou qui s'appelle métropolis qui est
un syncrétisme ans d'une part l'histoire
de capek qui est lu par théa von harbou
est réinterprétée par fritz lang
et puis l'imagerie américaine du robot
métallique de l'android métallique et
c'est la collusion de ces deux
imaginaires là qui apparaît être ou
source de m police qui l'a aussi
utilisent le robot comme une métaphore
non plus du capitaliste mais des
tendances perverses de l'homme on va pas
trop s'y attarder
le robot va subir une évolution assez
importante de belges adorent la séquence
incroyable quand l'android séduit tous
les hommes un petit peu dans une salle
mais les drummers vous savez qu'on
entend beaucoup parler depuis qu'on
parle de l'empathie chez leurs beaux que
blade runner est une référence source à
cette empathie oui puisque dans ce film
là la seule manière qu'il ya de
distinguer un robot d'un humain c'est de
lui faire passer un test le test de
l'empathie en l'occurrence on massacre
des animaux devant lui en général et le
robot falandry de la pas tellement de
réaction alors que les mois un peu
effrayé par la chose et ce test là
permet de distinguer les deux sauf que
si vous lisez ça en termes réalise
vous dites ah tiens on pourrait faire en
sorte qu'un jour des robots en soi fasse
preuve d'empathie
non non pas simulé mais vécu hors philip
k.dick l'auteur de bendtner on n'a
vraiment rien à faire des robots ce qui
se rend compte c'est que dans les états
unis des années 60 puisque le film est
adapté d'un roman des années 60 dont les
états unis des années 60
on est en train de faire en sorte avec
un système de consommation qui est vert
fortement critiqué par la contre-culture
à laquelle appartient philip k.dick que
faire que les êtres humains n'est plus
d'empathie entre eux autrement dit dans
le film les drummers les réplicants a le
mot américain réplique nt beaucoup plus
intéressant que le mot robot androïde
les réplicants sont des humains comme
vous et moi c'est juste qu'ils ont
abandonné leurs facultés empathique et
philip k.dick utilisent cette métaphore
du robot non plus pour parler des
conditions du prolétariat mais pour
parler d'une condition des années 60-70
de l'être humain des années 60-70 qui
perd son empathie à force de vivre dans
un monde simuler que le monde de la
consommation dans laquelle l'autre n'est
plus qu'un objet ou un objet de
consommation l'occurrence si on lit ça
comme ça alors soudainement le film
devient critique qui devient réflexif il
nous envoie une image de nous-mêmes que
de dire et vous êtes vous capable
d'empathie
parce que si vous êtes capable
d'empathie alors vous êtes un humain si
vous n'êtes pas capables d'empathie
qu'est ce qui vous distingue d'un
répliquant la réponse est rien et c'est
évidemment la même stratégie qui est
utilisé par molière dans son théâtre
c'est que si je me rends compte que moi
en tant qu'humain je n'ai plus
d'empathie vis-à-vis de mes semblables
alors je peux grâce au film ça marche la
mère de ses manières non plus mais je
peux grâce au film rendent compte que je
n'ai pas envie d'être cette rude être
humain sans empathie et donc je peux
commencer à modifier mon comportement
c'est pour ça que molière met en place
les femmes savantes si je ris des femmes
savantes et je me rends compte que c'est
une femme ça dort savante alors je peux
changer mon comportement
c'est ce qu'on appelle la catharsis ça
marche pas mais passons c'est en tout
cas comme ça que ça fonctionne à
condition que je vois dans les
réplicants des métaphores et non pas les
vrais robots qui serait un jour capable
ou doué d'empathie dire que les êtres
humains n'arrive pas ce qui est assez
étonnant c'est que cette figure du robot
1920 et 1970 en gros 1982 pour le film
blade runner de ridley scott va être
transformé par une nouvelle métaphore il
apparaît chaque fois dont le sens des
représentations des nouvelles métaphore
la flamme amoureuse
apparaît lors de la renaissance en
particulier ces retards elle n'existe
pas avant n'est pas de flamme amoureuse
c'est les grecs sauf dans les version
américanisée de la guerre de troie qui
passent sur les écrans actuellement mais
sinon vous n'avez pas ça donc il ya des
images qui apparaissent de temps en
temps qui permet de re décrire le monde
dans un roman assez peu connu mais qui
est à la source du film matrix 15 ans
avant puisque c'est vraiment une 1984
willem gibson un auteur américain de
science-fiction invente des invente
créer une intrigue dans lequel des êtres
humains se connecte à un espace qu'il
appelle le cyberspace et deviennent donc
des ia ou tout cas ce sont des humains
d'abord connecter à des réseaux
informatiques puis qui vont gentiment
être drogué à ce système informatique ce
qui tous deux un peu des deux jeunes qui
en particulier quand ils peuvent plus se
connecter et puis au bout d'un moment
ils quittent même leur corps humain pour
devenir des ia et là il se dupliquer à
l'infini
évidemment quand ils dupliquent à
l'infini le problème c'est qu'ils
perdent leur identité ça c'est un peu le
problème quand on est beaucoup nous
revend c est un roman qui seront 84 qui
avait passé relativement inaperçu à part
dans le champ de la science fiction et
qui est pourtant une des métaphores les
plus puissantes pour comprendre que
notre condition encore actuel d'êtres
humains pour parle en permanence
connectés c'est d'ailleurs quelque chose
qu'on peut lire à travers le film avatar
ce qui est marrant c'est que quand
gibson écrit le roman siens il voit deux
enfants jouer sur l'intérêt l'atari 2600
ou rappeler avait pas beaucoup de pixels
n'est pas beaucoup de couleurs mais il
dit tiens c'est bizarre ces enfants sont
en train de quitter leur corps pour
vivre dans un autre monde
et c'est exactement ce type de choses là
qu'on voit dans avatar n'ont pas une
fable écolo sur la base de pocahontas ça
faut vraiment lire ça au premier degré
un vraiment plan-plan quoi c'est comme
si vous pensez que madame bovary a
vraiment existé il ya un problème
d'interprétation
mais quand un film sort dans les années
2000 et qui s'appelle avatar qui est le
nom désigne et non pas pour parler des
divinités bouddhiste mais pour parler
d'abord des personnages qui nous
représente dans les jeux vidéo on se
rend compte que avatar 2 vient en film
est à fort et qui parle de la connexion
de la machine dans fin de l'homme dans
des réseaux numériques
je vous rappelle que jake sully
handicapés comme nous tous puisque nous
avons tous des lunettes 3d qu'on nous
voyons le film sex lies handicapés pas
paraplégique peut devenir une sorte de
poupée bizarre et assez moche qui est
traité seulement en images numériques à
la fin du film ils quittent même son
corps frêle
pour devenir ce pur cette pure image
numérique c'est la transition entre un
acteur on va dire une image réelle un
acteur profit milk l'acteur tel qu'il
est racette acteurs-là qui deviennent
pure image numérique
c'est exactement ce qu'il racontait dans
neuromancien quand je quitte mon corps
pour devenir un pur avatar 1
je vous rappelle que le pur avatar est
une des fantasmatique de ces mouvements
américains qu'on appelle le
transhumanisme aujourd'hui qu'ils
imaginent qu'un jour on pourra applaudir
nos cerveaux dans des serveurs
informatiques sas et les extrêmes mais
il ya quand même des gens qu'ils le
pensent et qui reçoivent plus d'argent
que gibson pour neuromancien ce qui est
intéressant avec ça c'est que de
nouveaux lits à 1 celui qui est connecté
à la machine celui qui devient en
logiciels informatiques pour faire
simple c'est pas d'abord un vrai
logiciel qui devient un logiciel
informatique c'est d'abord la tendance
bizarre urbaine à dénigrer son corps et
sa chaire en permanence pour ce fantasme
et à travers l'informatique autrement
dit
l'explosion du temps qu'on a aujourd'hui
sur les réseaux sociaux n'est pas le
fait que nous sommes tous des victimes
bien qu'on a toujours été des victimes
sont pas tous des victimes de grosses
boîtes américaines mais peut-être un
phénomène beaucoup plus large
postmoderne qui voit chez l'être humain
un rejet profond de sa chair dans
neuromancien 84,15 le héros dit je suis
tombé dans la prison de ma chère 1 et
que je peux m'en libérer je peux sortir
de ça je peux m'inventer davis je peux
devenir quelqu'un d'autre
plein d'autres personnes d'autres
laquelle est la meilleure métaphore pour
ne plus avoir de corps est être qui on
veut en dupliquant que l'ia ou que le
logiciel informatique va trouver en
moyenne de meilleure nouvelle que ça
être compliqué deux films un peu
critique et je terminerai là-dessus qui
montre aussi comment la science fiction
va creuser cette thématique là avec des
scénarios à chaque fois particulier
différent pour qu'on puisse s'approprier
les métaphores bizarrement on lit jamais
ses films comme des films métaphorique
transcendance le film où les fans de
johnny depp sont très content puisqu'il
est multipliée très souvent sur pleins
d'écran donc on le voit partout comme ça
oui quand vous avez cette phrase jeu
créant le jour où la technologie depa
sera l'homme dans un film de science
fiction ce qu on se rend bien compte
c'est que cette phrase dit aujourd'hui
la technologie a déjà dépassé l'homme
pourquoi parce que dans transcendance
vous avez un personnage qui est un
savant qui croise du stop
à l'importance du développement
technologique qui est victime d'un
attentat bon film américain oblige et
qui va être claude et se dire qu'il va
voir sa conscience intégrer un réseau
informatique et ça va le faire devenir
peut-on mission comme ça et puis il va
donc évidemment le fait qu'il ait plus
de limites humaines qu'il ait plus de
limites charnel il va commencer à faire
à peu près n'importe quoi en fait à la
fin ce qu'on se rend compte qu'ils
réalisent c'est juste l'utopie de sa
femme mais qui montre aussi que là on
n'est pas en train de parler de la
singularité technologique ou de notre
avenir
mais de cette espèce de tentations et je
trouve que l'affiché incroyable pour ça
ou l'être humain est de plus en plus en
train métaphoriquement de ceux numérisés
ça n'est pas réellement mais dans sa
capacité à être en permanence connectés
à des réseaux informatiques voire même à
avoir confié la gestion de sa vie à des
réseaux informatiques qui fait que cette
dépendance que l'on parlait le gibson
dont le nouveau roman siens elle est
déjà là essayez d'imaginer comment at on
coule tous les téléphones portables
pendant trois semaines je pensais à 2,3
dont - qui vont faire un peu des petites
crises cardiaques
je terminerai par mecs maquis d'al sais
pas si vous avez vu ce film et qui
combine tout ça qui combine les robots
et les ja ex machina ckoi jeune femme
relativement jolie qu'on voit jamais
vraiment complètement sauf à la fin on
voit que son visage le reste sur deux
robots qui est un robot
mais on apprend surtout que celia
suffisamment forte pour qu'elle ait
réussi à remplir à satisfaire le test de
turing dès qu'elle peut faire en sorte
qu'un être humain puisse se tromper sur
le statut à accorder à ce robot on met
un type qui ressemble à un petit peu à
mark zuckerberg donc un type un peu de
18 ans voyez pas très à l'aise avec les
femmes qui peut que tomber amoureux de
fait qui tombe amoureux voilà évidemment
et puis s'ensuit dans un ensemble de
péripéties pas très importante mais ce
qui se passe c'est que à la fin elles
arrivent à se sortir de sa réserve
on comprend que l'impôt emprisonnée elle
sort de ça elle remet sa peau sur elle
elle sort dans le monde réel et nous on
se dit mais c'est quand même terrible
ces machines qui vont prendre le pas sur
les humains
sauf qu'on a oublié quelque chose c'est
que ce être cette femme là avant qu'elle
puisse remettre sa peau n'est qu' un
robot à destination de gens qu'ils
expérimentent et qui veulent coucher
avec elle autrement dit quel meilleur
tu as for yat-il que l'instrument de
l'instrumentalisation sexuelle et du
fait d'utiliser quelqu'un à son propre
profit que de transformer en robot là
j'espère en tout cas que ces quelques
questions que se dresse rapidement mais
espère en tout cas que ces films nous
intéressons vous pourrez les voir
et rappelez vous que si la fiction est
intéressante c'est parce que nous avons
des métaphores que si les métaphores
sont intéressantes c'est que c'est des
seules manières qu'on a aujourd'hui de
réinventer vraiment notre monde pour que
notre monde reste lui contrairement aux
futurs humain voilà je remercie de votre
attention
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]